another sign las vegas is headed down
the right path on its road to recovery a
celebrity dj is making big noise today
after an announcement of a las vegas
residency
brian you know zed right i'm thinking
pulp fiction but there's a difference
he's going to be coming to a resorts
world this summer christian casadas
joining us now live near the strip with
more
on when the zed show is going to launch
christian
well denise and brian there are no dates
so far but rest assured that zed will be
making plenty of noise
come this summer inside resorts world
las vegas now
he is the first entertainer the property
has officially announced
that of course has many people buzzing
about now you might recall
singing to some of his songs like
clarity and the middle the 31 year old
russian-born dj
will be performing inside the resorts
world zuke nightclub
and a.u day club this summer on twitter
he expressed his excitement for the
brand new show he's working on with the
zoo group
tourists we talked to today said after
months of pandemic fatigue
they are ready to have a good time i saw
alicia keys here and that would be
awesome again
but we see usher's coming so you want to
come back fresher so that's awesome
but i don't know how concerts are going
to work now i mean are they going to be
normal
with kovacs well i mean i would go but i
don't know like are they going to let us
just go
like normal you know are we masked you
have to wear a bubble
well people are ready to get back to
enjoying some live music but the
question on everyone's mind
is what will that look like those
details i'm sure will come
as the dates get close so now among
other entertainers
coming to las vegas usher will have a
residency at cesar's palace as well as
sting
later this year billy idol will have a
short run at the chelsea
donny osmond will return to the stage at
harris and the jabberwockies
are at the mgm grand arena area now back
out here live
resorts world las vegas president scott
sabella
told us via email that zedd is a global
icon
and they're very excited to have him as
the first of an incredible
roster of dj so you can expect obviously
more names to be announced
very soon christian casadas 8 news now
christian this is great news and denise
jumping in now i mean the fact is we got
smith center coming back with the fall
lineup we have all the acts that
christian just mentioned from rock bands
to djs
this it's like that young woman said
what do i need to do i want to go
right tell me do i have to wear a mask
cool i'll wear a mask i just want to go
to the show
and by october who knows what the you
know the landscape is going to look
true start booking those tickets the
road to recovery i love this